Turquía arranca ya su campaña electoral
para las próximas elecciones
presidenciales y parlamentarias que se
celebrarán el próximo 14 de mayo en
Turquía y lo hace con la apertura de
este el primer portaaviones producido y
que tiene el ejército de Turquía que
será el primer portaaviones del mundo
que está exclusivamente pensado para
transportar drones de combate en vez de
aviones tripulados por pilotos en los
combates este portaaviones el anadolo ha
sido creado conjuntamente con el
ejército español y está siendo visitado
durante Estas fiestas de final del
ramadán que duran todo el fin de semana
por miles de ciudadanos turcos Cada día
que quieren ver esta nueva hazaña o este
nuevo proyecto que ha especialmente
comandado el presidente Turco y perdón
que busca a proyectos Como esos para
mostrarse como un líder fuerte ante sus
propios seguidores recordemos que erdoan
se presenta ante las peores elecciones
que se ha presentado nunca en sus 21
años de gobierno con una popularidad
histórica muy baja la del presidente
Turco que ve
como la grave crisis económica que
arrastra Turquía además de la mala
gestión según muchos turcos del
terremoto ha bajado la popularidad de
erdogan que ve también como la oposición
turca está galvanizada y cree
sinceramente Según dicen la gran mayoría
de las encuestas la oposición podría
ganar estos comicios de hecho según
muchos seguidores de la oposición y
ciudadanos turcos no entienden Cómo se
puede ahora mismo estrenar un barco como
este que ha costado millones a Turquía
producir comprar el diseño y trabajar
aquí en Estambul cuando en el mercado
los precios a los elementos han
disparado no en el último año sino en
los últimos meses incluido desde la
crisis del covid y se después sobre todo
de la guerra en